journée difficile où suis-je tu es mort c'est
une blague hilarante haha tu as des compétences que n
us voulons nous aimerions que tu rejoignes le RIPD
e RIPD reste en paix département et al
rs tu sens ce que je vends
ton travail est  attraper des dedos les
mauvaises choses qui échappent au jugement
rencontrer votre nouveau partenaire oh tu dois gagner
que je suis tout ce que nous sommes les plus grands hommes de longue date
qui aient jamais vécu et sont morts maintenant je suis en quelque
sorte caché parmi les vivants je
ne sais pas  quoi d'autre pour te tirer dessus il
y a quelque chose d'autre il te
ressemblera tu ne te ressembles
plus alors qu'est-ce que je ressemble vraiment à un
vieux chinois et toi
eh bien je suppose que tu gagnes
tu étouffes vraiment le wiki que nous sommes  avec
le ministère de la santé, nous resterons
tu seras peut-être mort tu peux soutenir celui-ci
mon régal non je ne le suis pas je ne vais pas
ne pas remarquer que nous sommes assez durables ça
fait toujours mal bonjour Shane a 44 ans si les morts
prennent le dessus c'est tout  Pour le monde vivant,
ils ont choisi le mauvais endroit pour prendre
position, ce monde est pour les vivants et
tous  bon Pete jour va le garder comme ça